[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica desde
Ciudad de México en esta ocasión
abordaremos el problema de la violencia
en el país 2022 cierra como uno de los
años más violentos en la última década
los meses de mayo y octubre han sido los
más mortíferos cada uno con más de 2.400
homicidios dolosos en la cifra acumulada
en cuatro años de gobierno de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador se rompió ya la
Barrera de los 130.000 asesinatos con
esto se superan los 120.000 ocurridos
durante todo el sexenio de Felipe
Calderón y podría rebasarse también la
estadística de los más de 156.000 del
gobierno de Enrique Peña Nieto de
acuerdo con datos oficiales del Sistema
Nacional de seguridad pública en
promedio se cometen 80 asesinatos
diarios En el país Guanajuato encabeza
la lista en número de homicidios en ese
estado ocurrió una de las mayores
masacres del año el 15 de octubre
durante el ataque a un bar en el
municipio de Irapuato donde un grupo
armado asesinó a personas presuntamente
por una rivalidad entre bandas
criminales por la venta de droga en la
zona Guerrero es otra entidad con altos
índices de violencia en el municipio de
San Miguel totolapan en la zona de
Tierra Caliente el 5 de octubre sicarios
abrieron fuego indiscriminadamente dando
muerte a 20 personas incluido el alcalde
y su padre exalcalde de esa localidad en
lo que ha sido uno de los multi
homicidios más cruentos de los años
recientes la violencia este año en
México ha sido gravísima porque la forma
como nos matamos es mucho más violenta
que en épocas anteriores no Y nosotros
hacemos un estudio hemerográfico donde
vamos tomando todo lo que nosotros
consideramos como una atrocidad sin
embargo seguramente hay más atrocidades
que los mismos medios de comunicación no
alcanzan a cubrir el presidente López
Obrador sin embargo sostiene que su
gobierno Ha logrado revertir por fin la
tendencia al de homicidios ya han
conseguido una disminución porcentual de
dos dígitos por ello ha reiterado en
distintas ocasiones que pese a los
reclamos no modificará su estrategia de
seguridad
Entonces no vamos a cambiar la
estrategia
al contrario
quienes deben de reconocer
que se equivocaron
y que los errores
en política
son como crímenes
en el mejor de los casos
son nuestros adversarios Pero además de
la violencia del crimen organizado otro
flagelo que ha afectado a México de
manera muy marcada en 2022 es la
violencia feminicida
hubo casos que tuvieron resonancia
internacional como el feminicidio de
deban y Escobar una chica de 18 años que
desapareció en la carretera Monterrey
Nuevo Laredo el 9 de abril y dos semanas
después fue hallada sin vida dentro de
la cisterna de un motel el caso sigue
impune o el feminicidio de Ariadna
Fernanda López una joven de 27 años cuyo
cuerpo apareció a un costado de una
carretera en Morelos había sido
asesinada tres días antes en la céntrica
Colonia Roma en la Ciudad de México hoy
un hombre y una mujer están presos por
su feminicidio se trata solo de dos
casos muy sonados de entre cientos que
ocurren en el país
este año lo que vemos es que continúan
los altos índices de asesinatos de
mujeres diez mujeres diarias en promedio
qué es lo que preocupa es que se
visibiliza más un patrón un patrón que
estamos viendo la que se está
visibilizando que ha estado pero hoy es
visible donde mujeres que desaparecen
las encuentran asesinadas es un contexto
donde ya se venía y se ha denunciado la
violencia contra las mujeres por eso el
país tiene 25 declaratorias de alerta de
género por contextos graves que están
poniendo en riesgo la vida y la
integridad de las mujeres según las
cifras del Sistema Nacional de seguridad
pública en los 10 primeros meses del año
el homicidio doloso y el feminicidio
disminuyeron siete y ocho por ciento
respectivamente Comparado con el mismo
lapso del año anterior sin embargo
siguen siendo cifras muy altas un
promedio de 2.600 asesinatos y 79
feminicidios por mes
la Secretaría de Seguridad insiste en
comparar la cifra de homicidios dolosos
con la ocurrida en el máximo histórico
de 2018
presentada así la disminución es de
13.9%, Sin embargo en diversas encuestas
aplicadas a nivel nacional la
inseguridad es considerada como el
principal problema de los mexicanos
Gracias por acompañarnos en enlace
Norteamérica desde Ciudad de México soy
Mario carbonell y mi compañera en cámara
Lizeth Romero Hasta pronto